cette salle de crossfit trappistes avait
ouvert ses portes en février dernier
mais au bout d'un mois d'exercice les
appareils sont restés orphelins de
sportifs confinement oblige
alors pour pouvoir rouvrir le plus vite
possible
le gérant a fait installer des parois
mobiles et des marquages au sol
l'objectif c'est d'être prêt avant la
date donc on est en train de voir on
travaille dessus encore et toujours pour
être prêt au maximum et pour éviter
comment dire d'être bloqués par les
strates et les restrictions d'état donc
on est on est déjà sur l'anticipation
c'est paroisse et cette signalétique
elles ont été fabriquées dans cet
atelier
lagence districom spécialisée dans
l'impression numérique installé à
trappes depuis 15 ans a vu son activité
augmenter en cette période de
déconfinement dans les quinze premiers
jours donc des fermetures dans
l'entreprise
on a fait donc des réunions
par internet et ce qui nous a permis
donc de mettre en place une stratégie
pour pour affronter le co vide donc le
souhait de districom ça a été vraiment
de proposer un catalogue complet où on
avait plus de 45 pages de produits
destinés aux qu'ovide l'entreprise est
également modifier certaines habitudes
de travail pour pouvoir répondre à la
demande le plus vite possible avec par
exemple la création d'un site internet
permettant aux clients de faire un
premier devis en ligne avant d'entrer en
contact avec l'entreprise
on s'est aperçu que la demande liée aux
qu'ovide c'était de pouvoir être livrés
très vite d'être livrés sur des produits
qui soient pas forcément des produits
standardisés mais qu'ils puissent est
des produits personnalisés
et c'est surtout cette capacité de
réagir entre la demande du client et la
livraison d'être à j + 1 j + 2 au grand
maximum quand on est en province donc
c'est vrai que ça nous a obligés à
réinventer notre mode de production
une fois les installations que j'ai
terminé l'entreprise revient à ses
fondamentaux et accompagne des besoins
en communication et autres enseignes
nécessaires à la reprise économique de
leurs clients
si cet épisode épidémique a freiné une
partie de la suite et liées à
l'événementiel en s'adaptant cette
entreprise a pu gagner de nouveaux
clients publics comme privés